in Italian Waters at a pace and matched
in recent years a wave of Migrant
Crossings continues this one of the
latest a fishing boat with 400 on board
taking on water out of fuel and no
Captain believed to be refugees
departing from Libya but becoming adrift
between Malta and Greece according to a
volunteer-run distress hotline calls for
help were ignored with claims Maltese
authorities ordered nearby ships not to
rescue the boat only Supply fuel
you need to be an investigation of what
happened you know why fish investor that
was in Greek search and rescue area need
to arrive to the Italian rest search and
rescue area to be rescued this is my
question
but I don't have the answer the answer
is in the hands of the governments
no response to Sky News from Maltese
authorities but finally as the boat made
its way to Italian Waters the Coast
Guard there responded and it wasn't the
only Italian call out this weekend
with over 2 000 people picked up
including 1700 refugees reaching the
island of lampedusa in 48 hours alone
dozens have lost their lives so far this
year in the Mediterranean Sea including
children after a shipwreck in February
Charities are worried about more to come
as official figures show the numbers
making Boat Crossings this year are up
nearly fourfold with an expectation this
summer may become overwhelming Adele
Robinson Sky News